this thing about the guy was at home
without a job hard blows past James and
throws it down
[Applause]
keep putting in buckets at the right
time and stop shot limit mr. Jackson
couldn't be able to job and hence gets
all the way to the rim
he's got 32 I would expect that he would
sit here at the fourth quarter now the
four seconds down to three James Harden
with his ninth three of the game
adjust the ball the ball does a lot
Westbrook finds that trailer in the
round with the stuff start back out
there or what I'll tell you what James
Harden is a playmaker
[Applause]
between a hard and Gordon got found
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a half a Hyundai forehead Padma
was already on his move and Billy had
time to pull back
[Applause]
boom is sitting right here for that
seventh game of the Western Conference
final in astonishment this is good to
keep its once again by the Thunder would
you start to take control of this know
exactly what to do with it on that play
both guys for the tournament to get a
play for their team
hardly
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that's nasty Ross
especially that close the time is over
to help good double team by Houston
[Music]
Oh
Wilt Chamberlain
well it's easy to under pre she ate call
charged as Westbrook has his
triple-double ball denial Abbott and
Devon Lane
down with three-point informating mine
to win Defensive Player of the Year as
well look at hook another turnover
[Applause]
it's Westbrook he'll be trying to defend
these smarting over there on the
opposite side the floor the defense by
Kyrie Wow water by James Harden sure to
his end
[Music]
[Applause]
the reverse is goodbye Russell Westbrook
keep an eye on his fitness level
remember he was listed as questionable a
little bit earlier this afternoon deeply
agent out of Arizona 26 years old
on the ice so hard and got it there's
Russell Westbrook all the waiters go
over to +12 kind of zig while everyone's
acting not filled it like Cleveland they
wanted multiple playmakers and kind of
take the load off of LeBron
[Applause]
and look at that dunk there I guess you
guys detected the timeout here Josie
we'll finish this up later
spider ate last night only about 30
percent though on the season it doesn't
East pretty good in there though what's
weird about Westbrook got it back
harden against Amir Johnson right over
the top of them nothing but strings
courses touch to score baskets it works
to the tune of a Clint capela double
clutch and then slam dunk by Harold
lively girls going to foul works of all
worlds but it's the Rockettes we were
able to collect it James Martin
it's a bucket in a box fired three times
in the first portals left up explode
little basket his burst is seconded not
you know I think marked before as hard
knocks out of 30 finally first one in
seven attempt much Brooke inbound
declines Paul George she'll take the
shot no over the top Westbrook muffle
the shot drives hangs to the left hands
expect my high school days a plague
gives Brown song play high school and
Adams kicks it over OKC has the ball
spent hesitation in and out by Mitchell
is nasty Adams so tough Friday and
Watchmen DC and worst in Miami
the walkers can move up I'm not sure the
offense report list by taking down
riddle number 30 in your program
it's got to finish it off now onion
takes it for 2 a.m. line beyond can't
wait to get a chance to see it and
there's how to pay a two-game total he
had 50 the last time he played on
Saturday night
make that 36 the benefit of the doubt to
the offending he brought his a-game
early
[Applause]
[Music]
Showtime can't convert he's brown on the
round takeaway from behind then his
shooters in the game
explosive score in the backcourt
he's Westbrook he lays it up cleanse it
off really like knocks like mudiay
he's not playing tonight
[Music]
love that step back I promise we're
gonna steal here by Russell Westbrook
how did he do that ban Texan Allah
as Westbrook hardened against gallows
cats a few can three plus one
boys attempts coming into this game he's
done over 500 get somebody had his hip
the first six years of his career is
like a nice drive there intend to finish
[Applause]
everything this season is going in for
James Harden this book wants to push to
the Thunder
[Applause]
pretty wide variety music between
Sheriff
it's ugly doubts people's trying to get
some stops Westbrook pull-up jumper got
it and a foul tariffs hit him on the
wrist Russell Westbrook with a chance
for a three-point play
[Music]
[Applause]
Justin all for the last seven West when
changing gears goes by Tucker bird isn't
defending the step free Hardin County
this is too good have to outplay another
elite player standing alongside there's
no way Westbrook wanted to come all of
them as well grant open look that's a
three
[Applause]
the sign for the Thunder defense that
that's the first three points between
the pick two for Portland now Westbrook
answers back to the trouble of his own
product tried to save it
Houston ball hard he's finally on the
board with his first field goal